we just want to bring you some breaking
news coming into us from Westminster
Daniel corski has dropped out of the
race to become the Conservative
candidate in the London mayoral election
following a claim that he groped a TV
producer in Downing Street this is Daisy
Goodwin who alleged that she was touched
inappropriate by appropriately by Mr
korski 10 years ago in newspaper
articles that were published in the
times and the Daily Mail Daniel corski
is all always vigorously denied those
allegations but he has withdrawn now
from the contest to be the Conservative
candidate for the mayor of London and he
has put out a statement this afternoon
which I'll read to you now he has said
I've decided with a heavy heart to
withdraw from the conservative mayoral
contest I categorically deny the
allegation against me nothing was ever
put to me formally 10 years ago nor
seven years ago when the allegation was
alluded to notice investigation has ever
taken place I've been clear I would
welcome and constructively participate
in any investigation however the
pressure on my family because of this
false and unproven allegation and the
inability to get a hearing from my
message of the London dream makes it
impossible for my campaign to carry on
Daniel corski goes on to say I'm proud
of having run a positive campaign that
championed new ideas technology and
talent and the years I've campaigned for
the conservative party and to make the
lives of londoners better he goes on to
say I believe strongly that londoners
deserve an uplifting and positive vision
for their city and I've tried hard to
offer that he said the news agenda is
becoming a distraction from the race and
the conservative party and he goes on to
wish the other candidates are well so
let's bring in Mari Aurora now our
political correspondent he's at
Westminster for us so Mari Daniel korski
pulling out of this mayoral race
yeah Daniel Kowski uh pulling out of the
Mayoral race I think a lot of people
were expecting this to come after we saw
those allegations where as you say daisy
Goodwin a screenwriter novelist and TV
producer had accused him of uh grabbing
her breast in a business meeting 10
years ago in 10 Downing Street now as
you read from that statement he says the
news agenda essentially these
allegations against him have become a
distraction from his campaign and
therefore he has decided to step down
now interestingly we know Daisy Goodwin
this morning on the radio 4 this morning
today program said she'd actually been
contacted by other women who had some
very interesting stories to tell her
about potentially their experiences with
Daniel corski as well so perhaps this is
only speculation but perhaps there was a
worry that maybe more stories may come
out one day and therefore it's best not
to continue with the campaign but he
also does talk about the pressure on my
family he says because of this false and
unproven allegation it's important to
remember he completely and utterly and
vigorously denies the allegations
against him of sexual assault by Daisy
Goodwin and also we know that he has
lost conservative backers in recent
hours and last night was the first uh
atori MP Robert Half and told to
exclusively to me at Sky News that
sources near him had said he had paused
his support for Daniel corski despite
originally in a campaign video that is
on Daniel corski's Twitter feed saying
he knows him very well and he'd be a
brilliant mayor and he's a fantastic man
then this morning on the breakfast show
with K Burley Claire coutinho an
education Minister said she was also
pausing her support for Daniel korski's
campaign to be London mayor as well so
also we may have seen a continued slew
of a loss of support from Tory MPS and
maybe even Tory counselors for Daniel
corski as the allegations continue to
rip his campaign apart so that is the
breaking news he's out of the race he
has pulled himself out of the race and
now it's a race between Mars Hussein and
also Susan Hall well yes and we did hear
today didn't we that Daisy Goodwin who's
making these allegations made a formal
complaint to the cabinet office and what
happens to that investigation as far as
We Know
well we're not sure yet what is going to
happen she has as you say said she's
contacted at the cabinet office and
lodged that formal complaint now we need
to see who is going to be investigating
that number 10 not giving us the details
on that yet they also very much didn't
want to be pressed on things like
whether they believed her or him whether
they didn't want to be pressed on the
details of the allegations because they
felt that could potentially preempt or
prejudge any outcome of potential
investigation so it remains to be seen
if and when that investigation does get
up and running but so far we also do
know Daniel korski had said that he was
already made made these allegations
aware to cchq because obviously this
happened 10 years ago and actually it
was about seven years ago that Daisy
Goodwin had written about it and her
experiences but she had not named Daniel
corski and in her piece in the times
this week she says the reason she
decided to name Daniel korski as the
person who had assaulted her was because
of the fact he was running for London
mayor and therefore that was the
Catalyst and she wanted to make sure
that other women would be feel free to
come forward essentially now when I
asked number 10 yesterday if Rishi sunak
felt that number 10 was a safe and
welcome environment to work in Four
Women his uh his spokesperson said to me
absolutely yes there are guidelines in
place there's the ministerial code
there's the civil service code there's
training and advice available but
obviously once again the conservative
party are again dragged into a scandal
around bad behavior and breaking the
rules but it is important to remember
Daniel korski very vigorously denies
that this ever took place